welcome back to my long over to you and
now retrospective review of one of the
most popular or unpopular depending on
who you're talking to Dragon Ball series
out there Dragon Ball super
last time I faced possibly my most
taxing challenge to date waiting my way
through two entire arcs of Dragon Ball
super in one failed swoop it wasn't
looking good in moments before I lost my
mind I figure in a shroud of light
appeared and whisper gently into my ear
to this day I still have no idea what
that ethereal voice said but the peace
and serenity ushered through it carried
my weary body to the finish line but
that was last time this is a new day and
a new totally not Marc I'm stronger
faster
this week we are tackling the arc that
finally starts introducing original
stories chronicling the adventure our
heroes go on to meet the task of an
inter Universal tournament so sit back
grow your beard skip showering for the
next three years and Kyle smash those
like and subscribe buttons because right
now we are diving into my review for
Dragon Ball super the universe 6
tournament arc
I think it's safe for me to say that the
recreations of the battle of gods a
resurrection at films didn't exactly set
the world on fire but instead towing
animation and Dragon Ball super is
reputation across the entire world you
simply couldn't escape it plastered on
every forum on every social media that
would mention Dragon Ball super the
memes were unavoidable fans clearly were
not happy we were tired of remakes we
wanted something new and boy did we not
know anything about how the animation
industry worked back then things
needless to say we're not going all that
well for Dragon Ball super
then enter the universe six tournament
arc let's see how this goes episode 28
the episode itself kicks off as Goku and
Vegeta our training on beerus is world
under weeks seen doing 50,001 thumb
one-arm handstand push-ups while wearing
incredibly heavy clothing out of nowhere
a blast crashes in the surrounding
forests waking up an angry beerus that
begins attacking goku and vegeta who as
we've previously established can barely
move it turns out beerus is brothers
Champa who we are told is fat in a
number of different and creative ways
desires the challenges brother to a food
competition Champa much like beerus with
his seventh universe is universe 6 is
god of destruction having gathered the
most delicious food his universe had to
offer
beerus brings some delicious food from
earth to combat universe 6 his best
efforts Goku
Cole shot the fat once again reinforcing
this to us in case we forgot in the last
six minutes and universe 7 wins the food
competition thanks to some cup noodles
Champa because of this desires to locate
his universes earth for their food but
finds out that it has long since been
destroyed during this exposition we find
out a host of information regarding the
universes in Dragon Ball super and how
they work each universe has a sister
universe that they share a ton of
similarities with totaling twelve
universes in all each one governed by an
angel and god of destruction beerus and
champa began to squabble leading to
their respective attendants having to
step in to stop the conflict Champa then
suggests that since they can't fight
each other they should host a tournament
between their respective universes a 5v5
tournament where the winner stays on to
face the next with the winner receiving
the super Dragon Balls
beerus agrees and so begins the arc I
actually found this opening to be pretty
good again not amazing but it hit all
the marks
introduced then established two vital
characters the plot of the coming
episodes and I'm always down for a good
tournament so
bring it on episode 29 beerus decides to
leave it up to goku vegeta to figure out
who their remaining teammates will be
for universe 7 with one caveat the
captain is to be a mysterious warrior of
beerus is choosing who is according to
him much stronger than Goku we fast
forward to earth where boma hits beerus
again establishes a plan to use the
earth's Dragon Balls to find the super
Dragon Balls before champu does all the
while he and vados are off creating the
tournament grounds however Shenron
doesn't know where the last remaining
super dragon ball is thus Bulma is
forced to create a super Dragon Ball
radar that she makes with ease by the
way and hey she has a sister I guess
using her sister tights his contacts
Jaco and Bulma now make out a plan to
search for the super Dragon Balls while
Goku and Vegeta find teammates it's a
nice little episode establishing the
stakes and unpacking all the setup of
the prior episode for us to better
understand what the consequences are
within the world episode 30 this episode
is trash I'm not even going to spend
much time on it it's just a crappy recap
episode of the last two episodes and
maybe a little bit of the other stuff
but I'm serious point is Goku Vegeta
recruit piccolo and Buu done next
episode 31 this episode is really weird
I mean I like it but I also don't so let
me explain the episode is centered
around the antics of Bullman and Jaco
the Galactic Patrol officer as they
pursue an individual called zou know
that by Jacko's own description can
answer any question asked often he's
sort of an all-knowing being and don't
worry I'll address that in a second but
once they arrived they realized that
they require an appointment an
appointment that they don't have and the
appointment weighing list is quite long
so it's a good thing that the person
ahead of jakka with the lion was a
low-life criminal that takes one of the
servants hostage Jaco incapacitates the
criminal with E is Navitus place in line
Wow that's convenient once inside they
gave the big zoom man some smooches
bulma's official cup sizes revealed and
Zhu no answers bonus question about the
super Dragon Balls I thought this
episode was funny and interesting in
parts and really forced and lazy and
others
I enjoyed the means with which Bulma and
Jocko gain access to the question room
but I hated that there just happened to
be a criminal there before like what are
the odds of that actually
happen additionally I like the idea of
boma taking the initiative to think of a
way that she can gain the upper hand
without force like the others do showing
that she is an active character in her
own right that will do what she can to
protect the earth too but the fact that
there is a plot device MacGuffin
character that knows everything is
absolutely ridiculous and is
horrendously lazy and it shows because
he wasn't used in the rest of the show
to date he was literally created to
teach us about the super Dragon Balls
nothing else well we did get the cup
size but who the hell cares about that
because the tournament is starting in
the next episode episode 32 what can I
say
I have a simple man I hear a tournament
is coming and I get excited this episode
does contain the start of the tournament
sort of but it also has a whole bunch of
setup but it's fun set up so I dig it
the episode kicks off with goku vegeta
inside the room of spirit and time or
hyper bye time chamber depending on your
persuasion as they trained for three
years upon exiting said room or chamber
both Vegeta and Goku have beards and
stink like nothing else so that's fun
wheeze has prepared a cube transporter
to carry the combatants I'm the
spectators to the area Champa and Vado's
have created the tournament grounds
within they meet Monica and the
strongest in universe 7 apparently and
Goku punched him in the face what a
weird thing to do to someone you just
met they arrive by the tournament
grounds meet the competitors and take a
test to make sure they aren't mindless
Goku scrapes by with a pass and majin
buu falls asleep entirely already the
team of universe 7 is down to just four
fighters Goku piccolo Vegeta and of
course Monica who beers and Cisco's last
Goku ops to fight first against the Xi
Jinping looking character named boot amo
and a penguin alien sings the national
anthem of the universe ending the
episode episode 33 okay so we didn't get
much action in the last episode but in
this would we get the conclusion to two
fights column two fights
Goku versus the president of China is a
first and Goku gets off to a rough start
but mostly due to him not having
digested his food from the trip over
properly he starts warming up doing some
squats and jogging as he dodges potaoes
blasts he eventually warms up and starts
going on the offensive but quickly
realizes that this isn't going to be as
straightforward as he once anticipated
botom OUC has the ability to absorb a
seemingly infinite amount of physical
punishment without any damage sustained
to himself however with that revealed
the means with which Goku can defeat him
becomes clear
judo throwing the bear out of bounds the
winner of the first fight is Goku and so
Goku moves on to the next round to fight
universe 6 his second combatant Frost
who looks like Frieza
only you know blue and apparently not
evil in fact he has a reputation in
universe 6 as being a very good person
according to cava the Saiyan from
universe 6 frost is a peacekeeper in his
universe acting on behalf of the weak
that can't defend themselves however
once he starts fighting with Goku it
becomes clear that he can't keep up with
the Saiyan
especially after assuming he's Super
Saiyan form which came much to Kaba
surprise as he has never seen that form
before apparently without seemingly
trying he puts frost on the back foot
catching his initial attacks
effortlessly beating him to a pulp
causing his legs to buckle and shake
beneath him
Goku requests a frost to quit but he
refuses moving in for one more punch
which again is blocked by Goku without
much effort but this time something's
wrong Goku falls weary and frost
capitalizes on this by knocking the sand
out of bounds Goku is eliminated now
that's what I call a cliffhanger episode
34 Frost has eliminated son Goku much to
Paris's dismay and so next up is piccolo
piccolo begins dodging frost initial
attacks opting to immediately charged
his makankosappo
or special beam cannon depending on your
persuasion through clever movements the
utilization of some defensive techniques
and along underutilize ability of his to
stretch his arms piccolo restrains frost
as he readies himself to release his
finishing attack when suddenly as Frost
moves his arm
piccolo too becomes weary and drowsy
creating an opening for frost to take
out piccolo completely incapacitating
him it seems that Frost has won the
match however this time Jaco has an
objection
armed with fantastic eyesight he noticed
that Frost much like during his fight
with Goku has broken the rules
utilizing a bar upon his wrist coated in
a fast-acting neurotoxin this is
considered cheating and so both piccolo
and Goku are reinstated and it turns out
Frost is actually super evil and in fact
causes the wars he acts as a peacekeeper
for once this is revealed Vegeta insists
that piccolo stands aside for him to
fight frost which he does without
complaints next up Vegeta vs. frost I
still don't understand why piccolo is
eliminated now for opting to switch
places with Vegeta but whatever episode
35 this
like many of the others that came before
it deals with quite a lot it feels like
and to be honest this entire arc has
paced itself rather well I think
maybe one or two episodes were a little
slow and one episode was entirely recap
but the vast majority has been quite
good at staggering its plot points and
story beats effectively in this episode
bajina eliminates Frost with one lonely
punch frost tries to steal the
tournament earnings while the next match
is being set up
hit intervenes however and incapacitates
frost turns out hits rather strong who
knew before the next fight begins Shawn
Pat creates a new rule the next match
will take place within a large box of
sorts huh anyway it becomes clear as to
why he does this as the match pushes
forward while magetta and the third
fighter from universe 6 can't fly he is
incredibly strong and gives off tons of
steam causing the arena to warm up
dramatically with Super Saiyan alone not
working for Vegeta and the air running
out in the arena
how will he deal with this new foe
episode 36 Vegeta getting desperate
throws everything at this tintype only
to have it either be thrown back in his
face or for it to have little to no
effect at all Gallic guns punches kicks
and evasive maneuvers having achieved
little to nothing for the same although
that a very close almost lost by way of
ring out causing Vegeta to lose his
temper forcing him to use the most
powerful technique in his arsenal
the final flash the charge here is
honestly quite nostalgic taking a lot of
cues and visuals from the original ones
in the cell saga the Lightning
surrounding the Saiyan spreads far and
wide as it envelops the entire planet
they are fighting on cutting up the land
and arena floor like butter Vegeta
readies his blast takes aim and fires it
towards magetta who to everyone's
surprise takes it like a champ Vegeta
then follows this up with a massive
punch and some insults which honestly
affected him much more than any of his
attacks ever did leading to the universe
6 spider getting knocked out of bounds
the match is over Vegeta is the victor
and up comes the next opponent for him
the Saiyan from universe 6 Kaba episode
37 in this episode we get introduced to
one of my favorite dynamics to develop
from Dragon Ball super period and it all
starts here the match begins Vegeta and
Kaba soon discover that they are pretty
well matched in their base form however
the situation for comma becomes clear
when he reveals he has never heard of a
Super Saiyan and
change in football and in the middle of
the fight he requests Vegeta to teach
him this appears to enrage the Prince as
he explodes into Super Saiyan
knocking Kaabah for a loop with a single
blow like frost before him he batters
and bruises the boy before grabbing him
by the scruff of his neck looking
straight into his eyes
promising to destroy his home and his
family with all this in the back of
kaaba's mind in insights and dramatic
transformation within it he's done it
he's achieved the legendary Super Saiyan
form and as he explores his new powers
and strength the Saiyan Prince Vegeta
cracks a smile apparently this had been
his planned the entire time this was his
means of training , he tells him to keep
pushing himself to never accept his
limit and to let the difference between
Vegeta and himself fuel his efforts
Vegeta transforms into Super Saiyan blue
shocking Kaba yet again the reflection
of Vegeta in his eyes of vanishes from
kaaba's view and before he even
registers his disappearance kava falls
the floor defeated Vegeta's last words
never forget this pain it's a great
episode and wonderfully establishes a
story and roll for Vegeta to assume as a
teacher for the next generation but
there's no time for celebration because
Vegeta has steamrolled through three of
universe sixes team now remains their
ace in the hole their final fighter hit
the assassin episode 38 all righty so
this episode and the next are sort of
where all the best action and business
occurs in the arc but despite the next
episode having everyone's favorite
moment I genuinely feel this episode is
the best one and we get a rare shot of
some blood too which if we are talking
about modern Dragon Ball is really rare
the episode kicks things off with Vegeta
now on his fourth opponent hit the foil
contested from universe 6 the bell rings
the referee matt and vegeta burst into
super saiyan blue now this is something
I thought was kind of weird but she
actually comments on the weak stance hit
assumes from the very beginning but
Vegeta is standing like this arms down
front facing with his face exposed
leaning forward not only is this a
terrible of fighting stance on a
fundamental level by Vegeta but this is
also the first time I've ever seen him
take a stance like this in this series
at the first sign of movement hit zhuzh
into action vegeta remarking that he's
very fast before taking and knuckle to
the mouth instead of taking things
slowly Vegeta launches forward before
once again being swatted to the side
with a strike
his neck the fight progresses much like
this more and more blows Landon Vegeta
as he continues to lose power to hit
we're marking to himself that he can't
seem to see hits movements at all and so
he devises a plan he allows hit tool and
a strike on him but this time he catches
the punch once he absorbs it this
catches even the incredible hit
off-guard and now with the assassin in
his grasp he could no longer die
Vegeta falls to the floor lifeless hit
is the winner
as the match wraps up Goku and Jacko
discuss hit and his movement with
Jacko's someone who prides himself on
his ability to see remarks that it's
like hit completely disappears what he's
attacking the king of the Galactic
Patrol who is also there sorry I sort of
glanced over that part at the beginning
he says that it could be a technique
known as the time skip a technique that
skips segments of time up to 0.1 seconds
allowing the wielder to attack unseen
Goku then makes his way over to the
starting point
passing Vegeta on his way he asks if he
has any advice for him Vegeta doesn't
have any apparently least this time has
the knowledge necessary to give Goku an
advantage here or to at least level the
playing field but he sees this as
training reassuring beerus in a joking
manner that they still have universe 7
strongest fighter for naka waiting in
the wings
Manaka it's revealed is a fraud without
being aware of this Goku is universe 7's
last hope the fight begins yeah this is
all in the same episode by the way the
Reedy is a lot in this one it's
definitely an underrated episode I think
because of its proximity to the next
episode it goes on to ask oku why he
hasn't transformed Goku explains that he
doesn't know how to beat him yet and he
wants to save his stamina for later the
attacks from Goku come from a number of
different angles all while evading and
faking shots all to no avail hit at this
point recommends that he give up as
taking so many hits to his vital areas
could end very poorly for him Goku
smirks and refuses because apparently
he's found an opening Goku
launches forward moves to strike but
instead blocks anticipating his
technique once blocked switching again
to offensive Goku swings his fist
towards the time skipping assassin
grazing his cheek with his knuckle and
look purple blood spoiled in this
episode we are
attacks again anticipates the attack
blocks it and anticipates where he'll
move once again landing his second
consecutive unanswered blow the to go on
to explain that they will start taking
things seriously from this point on
ending the episode episode 39 this
episode is pretty much all action
kicking things off in Super Saiyan blue
we see hits perspective of attack for
the first time as he is once again taken
off guard by Goku only this time he
lands square on his back attack after
attack Goku is getting the better of the
assassin coupled this with some
wonderfully on model artwork and you had
yourself some great scenes it does some
sort of fake power explains that he's
not like Goku and the others and can't
just power up by screaming and we'll
just have to improve on the fly using
his own abilities and he does just that
increasing the scope of his time skipped
longer and longer because of this
improvement Goku is knocked to the floor
once again with another heavy series of
attacks struggling to his feet he
reveals that he has to resort to his
secret weapon a technique not yet
perfected that runs with a massive risk
nowhere have I heard that before
that's friggin right with absolute
favorite move and all of Dragon Ball has
made a guest appearance in Dragon Ball
super as the Big Finish to the battle
I'm obligated to like this as a result I
can totally see why this is a lot of
people's favorite moment I mean how
could you not it's incredibly exciting
don't not spectacularly build up to by
any means but not bad either
I suppose the aspect of this that I
really enjoyed was how I wasn't
expecting it and how it sort of made
sense to couple it with Super Saiyan
blue given how we know that form works I
remember seeing this for the first time
at like 1:00 a.m.
lying in bed trying to contain my
excitement the entire arena is enveloped
in the red glow of the kaio-ken Goku is
too fast and explodes from the arena
landing a clean strike against the
freshly powered up hit he charges and
fires his kamehameha at hit ending the
episode quite the phenomena
episode 40 oh but wait it's a it's not
the finale Goku and hit go back and
forth a bit longer but it's obvious that
the best part of the fighting is over
really eventually Goku's body starts
giving him trouble before he chooses to
forfeit the match entirely refusing to
act as a pawn for beerus and champa
besides now it's Monica's turn he gets
to watch him fight it recognizes his
sacrifice and repays his debt to Goku by
throwing the match against Monica to
universe 7 is the winner Manaka the
victor Champa is extremely angry and
threatens to destroy his losing team
that he created but it's cut short as
some tiny figure flanked by some tall
gentlemen arrive on the stage beerus and
champa look worried
episode 41 it's revealed that this is
Lord Zeno he's pretty much the superior
to bearish Champa and everyone really
including the Angels Goku
but being Goku walks up to Zeno and
strikes up a conversation Zeno actually
really likes him then a reprimands
beerus and champa before announcing that
he did really like this tournament and
that he will hold a tournament similar
to this in the future after that it's
time to make the wish in the super
Dragon Balls apparently the last one
that they were looking for was the very
planet they were fighting on the dragon
is called forth and look it looks
embarrassingly bad like like really poor
clipart kind of bad it looks awful and
the wishes made whatever
beerus wishes the champers universe got
it's earth back if it's the sweet wish
whatever and that's Dragon Ball super
third arc just when things were at their
worst Dragon Ball super delivered some
of its best well maybe that's going a
little too far I mean the animation
largely was okay not spectacular the
story was very by the books despite some
moments of genuine interest here and
there it is a million miles better than
the first arcs but why don't I have
better things to say about this one well
despite me really getting a kick out of
the kaio-ken moment the fight between
Goku and hit is really lazy I thought
the beginning is by far the best part
watching Goku feel out the situation
trying to figure it out but the second
half is just move after move coming out
of seemingly nowhere to even or flip the
odds in favor of the next fighter it
just randomly gets better I mean I don't
get anything out of that it's not
interesting also it's a tournament arc
that didn't have a resolution a final
winner well I mean it's sort of did I
mean maracas but come on is that how you
want to end this yes I hear the comment
section sweets
I suppose the promise of another more
impressive tournament down the road is
something but I would have liked a more
concrete finish to this contest and not
just a ribbon on beerus and champa
relationship with that said it did
deliver a moment I really genuinely had
excitement for but let's not forget that
this is less than a third of the way
through this series there's still a
metric Frick ton of anime still to watch
and review and after this I'm
reenergized and ready to review the very
plan goku black arc if you want to keep
up with my ethics and this series make
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell if you actually want
the subscription to work but now do it
for this week I've been totally not mark
and thank you so much for watching
you
[Music]